you know those movies where you pull on
a branch the snake comes down here
[Music]
I'm not a huge fan of the forest
I think forests are beautiful but you
don't know what kind of creatures are in
the bushes oh I have a lot of hobbies
such as watching anime with my dog
playing video games with my dog video
editing with my dog actually most of
them are the hobbies you might expect a
12 year old to have I like to do puzzles
I love video games I'm not a fan of
being out of breath or super sweaty I
don't like feeling gross according to my
wife if it were left up to me I would
almost never get off the couch I prefer
the beauty of nature through like a car
window I also am worried that I'm going
to get sunburned my name is Justin nice
to meet you I'm gonna be your spiritual
guide to the woods of life my first
impression of justin is that he looks
like he's sculpted out of rock and
ancient Greek times our first game is
hide and go seek but the rules are a
little different the team that is hiding
wants to be found
we're using things in nature to give you
clues to find us what happens if we
never find you I'm not here to try to
change them but I would love them to
have the feeling that there is a
positivity being in nature I'm feeling
pretty sweaty and gross we're obviously
more one with nature than they are ah
that to me is a bad idea baby
oh I hope none of this is poison oak
this seems like a good spot oh this is
perfect okay so we're on the path I told
him to go off the path if video games
have taught me anything yes we should go
that way yeah I don't love the incline
you don't like the NCLEX be honest so
we're gonna strip but it's like a trail
oh my gosh
yeah not that very much view a lot more
fun hiding than finding it was also kind
of like a sneaky hike cuz was if you
told me like you're gonna go on a hike I
don't like oh come on that's not yes but
you're like hide-and-go-seek and I kind
of distracted me on and I was like wait
a minute we just went hiking here all
right guys what do you say we go on our
hike I guess it just feels really good
to actually get off the couch and start
moving and there's a really nice breeze
now our 73 it's okay here we go check
that out it was just a real calm serene
feeling I'm here I'm present I'm in the
moment I'm enjoying myself right now
instead of thinking about what the next
thing might be this is definitely
something I would want to do again I
would have never done it on my own but
now I want to bring all my friends up
here I don't have friends to do this
kind of stuff and I probably would not
even have known this magic even existed
the next time my wife asked me if I want
to go hiking I'll be able to say yes and
I'll mean it I learned that the world
outside of video games is just as
beautiful
[Music]
so I made a new friend on a hike name is
Ronald he's very small but he's bent
there a lot and he stuck with me through
my journey
[Music]